[Music]
look very well thank you thank you I
appreciate it so do you and as do you oh
thank you yeah that out of the way
exactly now let's get down what can we
improve yeah
no I would say yeah I thank you I mean
I'm kind of uh he's probably the hair
right it's probably the hair yeah it's
good yeah I'm getting to a cone in
height I realized as I was walking out
here I'm um I'm almost at that point
where I could I probably could get there
if I were actually there's enough I
haven't washed my hair in six weeks
That's not me I mean first of all mine
is very is down a little bit tonight it
happens it's moody but sometimes it's
yeah I can get like a nine inch lift up
here sometimes who do you have to think
of to get that innuendo you're not
supposed to shout innuendo after you
make an innuendo you're just not
supposed to that's what she said I find
that that the higher the hair goes the
the the less likely people are to look
at your face and therefore it does help
with people thinking you look good
you think that's true not you but I mean
me just in general
oh I thought you were talking about me
for a second I was gonna be really sad
kind of a power the you ever did when
you're at home did you ever like you
know bring it down at all like what
would you know I mean or salt or do you
wear like that all the time
it's wear like this it's just it's got a
springy action but yeah I could bring it
down I suppose I could I could pull it
forward
[Applause]
this is a whole new show you should just
cut backward finish talking
[Laughter]
it's just like the weirdest boy was that
a storm have you ever shaved your head I
know uh you know some of the young
people yeah I go out there or I see some
of the interns that work here and the
guys they shave their head you know what
was doing that in my day I tell ya no no
unless they're in the military maybe I
would I have shaved my head while I had
someone else save it actually when I
played basketball in college community
college you know so you know it's sort
of anyway um we a bunch of us shaved our
heads and yeah I took like a you know
one of those razors and I just you know
cut it all off and had like a little you
know crappy goatee like that and and a
lot of acne and yeah I was just a really
amazing it sound like I got myself some
of that act neither yeah it was pretty
great taught me character yeah so I did
I did that and I and there are a lot of
people and maybe again maybe you have
the same thing with with having a hair
that like that I you know either don't
washer put like you know hair product
and a lot of people coming up to like
touch and be like what's in there also
grabbing it to see if it's you know a
wig or some having a shaved head I have
never had more at that point of my life
girls like like like rub my head a lot
of times like they rub your head you
know yeah they love the sensation or I
mean guys too for that matter you know
in fact mostly guys mostly guys it was
mostly men it was mostly men one woman
who did it to you if you want me to be
honest you know is all guys and but yeah
they're you know he's just a nice little
sensation and do that and I wish I had a
photo of it if for no other reason and
to remind myself to make sure I never do
it again
but it's so cuz I think it would be
annoying if people came up on like it is
especially with that voice yeah that'd
be awful
get out of here Mickey Mouse you know
come out no I really want to rub your
head all right well hop up here and rub
it little guy
[Laughter]